this episode brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block pizza at 1811
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles consider
gray block what's up you little sassy
Thundercats huh heel old nippled gristle
lurkers how you guys doing how you guys
doing it's a wild time baby
I was thinking you know tech Tech is the
new fossil fuel you realize that
broadband is the new oil think about
that broadband is the new oil am i nuts
I might be man I just might be get in
[Music]
thank you guys for being here good day
to you 30 miles on the Gulfstream
I hear the South window the bridges
getting lower
the shrimp boats coming
the old man down in the corner slowly
turned his head takes a sip from his
whiskey pile and this is what he said I
was born in the rain on the pots of
trade
underneath an oozy animal don't mind the
strain of a hurricane they come around
there at you
the high black bottom a devil's daughter
she's hearts it's covered she's me
but nobody told her it takes a lotta
water to wash away New Orleans man came
down from Chicago he gonna set that baby
right it takes a whole lot of water to
wash away New Orleans and that song
right there is hurricane by band of
heathens and that song was submitted to
us by our listener Josh Wilcox and Gordy
from the band gave us permission to use
it and I know there's a lot of people
out there struggling or have been
struggling with the rent with the rains
and the struggling over there you know
hurricane Florence you know and that's a
watery [ __ ] it's out there you know
that brackish bad girl she's out there
you know just being a real honestly a
real [ __ ] and I know that that water
you know it's probably hit a lot of
people's possessions you know you see a
lot of people struggling out there a lot
of people you know just or a lot of
people gonna be going back to their
homes and and things aren't gonna be
there you know and I was just thinking a
lot about that you know I was thinking a
lot about like if you take off you know
you take my shirt or you take and you
take my hat or you take my you know it
could be for a for a child it might be a
teddy bear or a blanket you know my
favorite sheets when I was young I had
these Smurfs sheets and I always felt
like for some reason I slept so much
better when I had those on my bed you
know for a teenager it could be a laptop
or a cell phone for an adult it could be
a watch maybe it's a watch that your
your dad gave you your grandfather or a
locket or something your mother gave
your grandmother or a dress or a wedding
dress you know something the people
going home and something that they
cherish it gonna be there and all
they're gonna be left with is not all
they're gonna be left with but
you know it swab when we take away when
those skins those skins that we the
luggage the things we carry when those
are gone when those get taken away we're
just left with ourselves you know that
can just be under snow that's gonna be
trying it's gonna be tough for a lot of
people so just know that you're not
alone you know that people are thinking
about you and and we'll find some places
you can donate we're going to donate
through our patreon we're gonna donate
and we'll find a couple of links some
places you guys can donate that are
legit sources of places to donate if you
choose to I'm not saying you have to but
we're gonna look up some good ones we're
gonna make some donations from patreon
and uh and yeah that's when all the
things are gone who are we You Know Who
am I left with when I when you know when
I'm just standing there I mean I got
when all my little accoutrements and my
doodads and when that's all no and
that's all been waterlogged but mother
nature's coming back and just you know
she's good she got that you know that
saliva just she's just soggy and your
whole world up but that takes a lot of
faith in that moment a lot of just man
you got each other at that moment you
know I'm sure that that really you know
I'm sure that's a real test of who all
who am i you know way can I do this you
know can I put my family on my shoulders
can I you know can I not
you know stroke can I not show my fear
in front of my children can I you know
just I'm sure it puts a lot of things on
a lot of parents especially a lot of
parents shoulders so just know that
you're not alone this week and that
other people are thinking about you you
know I was inspired this week man I was
over there in Nashville uh and man when
I tell you had a great time man I had a
great time out here here's a call that
came in as I saw somebody's at the show
hey Theo this is Brooke from Austin I
was in Nashville this past week and I
took my coworker to see your show on
Friday night The Late Show and we had a
great time in hilarious we actually met
you I
her word and dude honestly I don't know
F what happened but I was so nervous to
meet you that I just like turned into an
alien or something I think I I think I
blacked out maybe you blacked out you'd
like what do you mean like you ended up
datin brothers after the show or what
are you talking about young lady
homeward um my mind was completely blank
and I couldn't even think of like words
to say to you the thing I just kind of
walked up to you and said my name maybe
hey well that's a great place to start
you know and I just appreciate you
coming out Brooke I'm glad you had a
good time I'm glad you brought your
coworker out that's sweet of you you
know and a lot of people came out I just
wanted to put your call in there just to
just to say thank you for coming and so
I was probably nervous to look it's
nervous for me like I'm meeting a lot of
people and you don't want to be
respectful of people's time and you know
a lot of people you know they got their
lady with them or and you don't want to
be you know you try not to ogle and look
at their lady's breasts or nothing
you're trying to just be a natural you
know a comfortable legal adult and be
you know you know be legitimate in your
own you know make good brain choices and
not be trying to brain down on someone
you know somebody's bro this one guy
brought a lady out yeah my own my dude I
look if they drove past a dairy farm
bruh I'll be damned if somebody wouldn't
hurt her up bruh she had them straight
up milkers on her son she had some look
I've had 2% she had about this lady
would have had 40%
she had them just them you know what I'm
saying then let safe you know them let's
say bad boys you know them leche mala
leche Malo at hermanos I mean she just
do you couldn't you need a do that look
if I if you motorboated that man you'd
have to have you better hope that a a
game warden comes by on a [ __ ] in his
little boat and checks on you because
you could drown out in there you could
drown this lady had no joke
I even told her husband straight up I
said bro I said look I love you I'm
respectful of you guys but your wife got
them danger bags out here because dude
they had like I had a dog about a half
block away and this dog stopped and
looked the dog stopped and looked at
human adult breasts so that's when you
know boy she had a couple of [ __ ]
just ribcage pluto's baby I mean just
two [ __ ] big old space shuttles on
her chest man real real hitters but but
thank you for coming out I want to say
that and also we had some people that
that that that ass kid that escaped the
storm they they you know they had to
relocate and they came out to the show
and I thought that was really really
awesome I want to say the guys name was
Tyler I can't remember exactly but I
know him and his girlfriend came out and
they had a great time and and that just
you know it felt so good to be a part of
you know just making something good man
we had fun dude we had so much fun in
Nashville man somebody came and brought
me some treats some Louisiana treats boy
a little bit of coffee and chicory and
I'm gonna have you ever had that coffee
and chicory bruh chicory will make you
just turn into a squirrel bruh you know
I'm saying
check chicory dude chicory will give you
that [ __ ] like nickname me you know
you know that face you make when you
even call him acog chicory will make you
do that man with no corn just me no Sam
boy check real turn you into something
turn you into a little a little tree
squirrel you know or just even a little
tree mouse chick a real geek give you
that get get you know that's that bass
you know that's that bass line that's at
nature's Tourette's right there that
yeah yeah
chicory boy make you seem like you're
[ __ ] like your heart like you like
your spine is doing little sneezes so
you know like
okay chicory get back in it it'll turn
you up they brought me on some prawns
from New Orleans man just some nice
treats I got somebody mmmm maybe this
nice bracelet they got somebody else
brought me some bracelets one of them
said onward one of them said you are
loved one of them said get that he had a
dude that I look man I just want to
thank you so much everybody that came
out of Nashville I cannot thank you
enough
Oh breasty Jeff came out Brisky Jeff
remember Jeff was somebody that called
in and he had speaking of breasts and
this might be a breast of sewed this
might be the breast of sewed ever he had
them you know the man to tots and he had
a boy and look so he comes up we start
talking he's there with this lovely lady
next thing I know he's like hey man it's
me Jeff and I'm like and then I turned
to the line there's a line of people
there and I said guys it's Jeff with the
tits and he broke the tits out then boy
tots you know and look man I'll tell you
this but you know I'm saying I'm in the
women you know I prefer women unless you
know it's you know I'm stuck on an
island and dude is [ __ ] being real
and some dude is being real nice to me I
prefer women you know this beep referee
NCI is you know yellow chupa chupa chupa
and um and uh but man he had some
[ __ ] I mean he had some just just a
couple of little just mmm
they look like mounds are kind of just
hard honey bruh I mean they were bees
too they were not you thinking A's
aren't you some of y'all are thinking
lowercase A's or uppercase A's know he
had them [ __ ] so I mean bees but also
look like each one I'm had maybe a staph
infection it was you know they were
taught they were just some taught bees
and they were beautiful and the whole
crowd cheered her who's like
hey that's Jeff with the kids and then
some lady got pissed she's like at her
husband he's like don't be looking at
that at that man state like time dude
people are turnin out around here I
think we had so much fun man so many
great people came out a young lady named
Ali came out I want to thank her
Jeff breasty Jeff came out man you know
he came out with his lady and if you're
on the youtubes were flashing pictures
of of both of those people and we'll
throw a couple of other pictures of some
people that came out to the show who
else
I mean just so many people came in and
you know brought gifts and nice things
and and just made it such a memorable
experience man Nashville is beautiful
Nashville is beautiful and did I'll be
honest I'm thinking am I going going
there in a couple of months and maybe
looking for a place and having the
opportunity to you know to be back and
forth in between places and just the
vibe there is good man the vibe there is
good and thank you so much for coming
out to zany's this weekend oh dude so
the manager one of the managers there
his father passed away right I don't
know if he put this on my head's on my
Instagram and and look we're all gonna
pass away you know I'm saying so if you
think in your brain you gonna be out
here forever then I mean you wouldn't
want that you don't want to be 900 years
old you know whenever you don't even
know any nobody you even know even knows
anybody that you knew growing up you
don't want that right so we got to go on
you got to go to that next you know into
that next womb you got to pop out of
that necks of a gene into the nether in
you know into another galaxy
pop pop dude you know and the crazy
thing about being born is that you come
out headfirst dude in that crazy you
never been into a universe before
there's a new galaxy and you straight up
pop out headfirst out of somebody's
garage that is
it's really bizarre it's really bizarre
because that's why if somebody's breech
birth
I'm like oh this is a this is a if
somebody's breech birth I'm thinking of
this person you know is makes good sense
they make good choices they go feet
first into a new galaxy because that's
really the way to go you know one foot
in one foot you know I'm saying go just
you know but some creep a Potamus node
who goes headfirst I don't have a
frickin in the vid world
it really is it's ridiculous really some
all I'm not that breech birth gang bruh
BBG so until I D ie
and uh and who else came out man
everybody came out we had a good time a
couple people came out that had babies
that had children coming man it was it
was just really really special and we
and all the shows were sold out and I
met so many great people and it means a
lot to me there were some people on what
I know they wanted to talk more and I
wanted to talk more and and by Saturday
night on The Late Show I'm usually just
kind of exhausted man it's uh you know
it's just a lot it's a lot of talking on
the stage and but man it was awesome I
had such a great time I went for a run
around Vanderbilt University I enjoyed
that what else happened and that's you
know that was kind of it you know I I
caught up on some rest during the day I
try to get out to a meeting and I didn't
get to one and my apologies for not
getting over there and that was it man
you know it was something bro it was
something else though but thank you to
everybody that came out the people that
are out there struggling and you know
that I mean that were displaced or
people that are getting back to their
homes and they're gonna be missing some
things just you know just know that
you're not alone you notice know that
you're not alone that people are
thinking about you and praying for you
and just hoping that
you know that uh that greater things
internal things greater I mean just the
probably the feeling you're gonna get
you know like I'm imagine how a hug
feels with someone you love after
everything you have is gone
and I know that's crazy maybe that's an
obtuse way to think but man that a hug
with someone you could love it could be
a family member it could be a you know a
camp counselor if you're of age you know
don't be you know don't be doing some up
you know on you know not right but uh
but imagine how that hug feels knowing
that you got something you got somebody
else and so if there's any about their
film like you know they lost it all just
know that you got us people are thinking
about you oh man oh what else is going
on oh I was looking at the news and they
had the this guy Kavanagh is supposed to
be the new Supreme Court guy and they're
just ripping this dude I mean they've
ripped him about three bungholes by now
and I think some things are good in this
we're in this time where it's like now
people are really starting to
investigate who candidates are you know
and but then some of it's like you know
they've been beating this dude up and
down the branches for a week or whatever
and and probably a lot I mean I mean
these days it's like if you're a white
person you're kind of you know you're
kind of [ __ ] or your people are trying
to pin a lot of tails on the ELMO on
that white donkey and look that you know
everybody's got to take their turn be in
the donkey and but I just feel like at a
certain point that they seem like
they've been unfair to this guy in the
sense well this is what happened now
they have a woman who was you know who
claims to be that she was she claims to
be have been sexually assaulted by him
thirty five years ago when they were in
high school
and they were drinking at a house or
something kids were drinking and he made
advances towards her he was aggressive
towards her and and she ran out of the
place and I have no clue if that happen
or not I have no idea but what I start
thinking is like like if people if you
did something in high school and this is
30 years later 20 or even you know 15
even if it was 15 like at this point are
we there's just never gonna be anybody
that can be a role model anymore we've
all made some mistakes in our life if
you went back to a high school everybody
I know in high school at some point was
either a per was either Pervin or ho and
every bet it said look pick a night some
at some party at some event at something
people if kids with sexual do you just a
booyah base of hormones at that point
and I understand we say well do this man
is supposed to be a judge you know on
the highest court in the land
well yeah but but it's what I'm saying
is like there's there no more
understanding anymore because otherwise
no one's ever gonna be able to do
anything dude if you look at the the
poor choices I made when I was in high
school dude I met now I made a lot of
great choices you know but but if you
look at the poor choices dude I remember
being at a party once I've talked about
that I've talked about this before and I
was wasted wasted all right you know I
just remember being at the party and
then later buddy man I was living with
his family and he comes and he he put me
in a headlock and I had a piece of steak
I had a little cut of steak or um you
know sirloin skirt meat and skirt meat
is I'm sure has a different you know
down in Tijuana that's got a different
you know connotation but I'm talking
about natural skirt steak from
animal and I had a little bit of that in
my jaw and he came in the house and
started choking me man
and it's hard dude it is hard to eat a
piece of steak and get choked out at the
same time because it's you need all your
throat to get a piece of steak down
sometimes and if somebody's you know
throttling on your neck and they put you
in that hard scarf it's hard to be
natural but he goes do what happened
this girl at the party said that you hit
her or said you pushed her down and did
I had no recollection of it I had no
recollection of ever even speaking to
that girl I knew the girl he was talking
about she was a friend of mine she was a
friend of mine she was a girl that I
thought was cute that I had you know
that I thought was funny and charming
and sweet and he told me that man and it
broke my heart you know and it broke my
heart and broke my heart the next day
when I was you know more sober and and
he told me about it
and man I you know I went and took her
flowers and I asked her you know what
had happened I don't even remember what
she said but she I could tell that that
she knew I was sincere and that I didn't
remember it and I could tell that uh
that I think I felt like she forgave me
she said she did and I'm I brought it up
to her years after that as well and
repeatedly I would just to check in and
make sure that she was okay but what I'm
just saying is like what if I went to
get a job at a manager you know what if
I wanted you know be a manager to
Staples or something like that and
somebody says comes and says well you
did this when you were you know 15 20
years ago I will [ __ ] man yeah it's just
like everybody everybody makes some
mistakes
everybody does things and here's the
thing it's like we don't know who you
know at 35 years ago you know they don't
know if this judge did it or not
I mean only he knows and and and the
woman knows exactly what happened but
it's just like what the [ __ ] man like
you know
at some point people are human beings
it's almost like we're holding people
accountable to something that's not even
realistic everybody's made a mistake
everybody's done something wrong you
know why because we're [ __ ] people
that do [ __ ] wrong that's what we are
the definition of people should be the
beings that do [ __ ] wrong sometimes so I
don't know man that's just just got me
act out it's like we gonna with it
what's next what if you hadn't done
anything what if you had never even been
accused of doing anything this man mr.
Cavanaugh or Cavanaugh I'm not sure
exactly say it but it's just like
they've beat up this man's character
like nobody's character is is press and
it's just like every law have we lost a
place of understanding and I don't think
we have I don't think we have I think
that the news has I think that you know
the news wants it to be that people are
angry the news wants us to be angry the
news wants us to fight each other and
think oh everybody's now racist and
everybody's this and everybody's a sex
offender I don't think a lot of people
are and you know and who knows maybe
this guy will come out and say see you
know he did something worse than than
what they're accusing him of but we've
all made some poor choices man you know
I mean it for the rest of my life you
held me accountable for you know for
being aggressive with this girl at this
party and when I was drunk as a child
and didn't remember as a teenager not a
child and didn't remember it you know
would that be fair I don't I don't think
I feel like it wouldn't be I feel like
it wouldn't be I don't know it's just as
crazy we hate we holding people do a
while to steam and not even a real one
we're holding people with something
that's not even real
nobody's perfect man you know nobody's
perfect maybe you let him sit down and
talk about it I mean it's just I don't
know I don't know what I'm getting off
on but
anyway man and what else is going on we
had some great calls that came in I'm
gonna be in Toronto coming up this
weekend and I'm fired up about that what
else oh then I'll be in Charlotte and
then I'll be in Appleton Wisconsin I'll
be in Phoenix
Buffalo Salt Lake City and washington
d.c I want to tell you what I got on
right now in my pants and I have on me
undies that's right these bad and they
holding that low brisket and then
baiting them daddy Jules brah do you
think how much DNA is inside of your
crotch in your nuts really fascinating
isn't it think about all your ideas all
your future whatever you though your
whole family your great-great
great-great grandparents part of them is
living inside of your nuts and so don't
you want to take care of your nuts with
something decent and wrap them in
something soft
well that soft thing can be me undies
they're the best underwear they use a
micro mode ow fabric which is three
times softer than regular cotton due to
view ever have you ever seen regular
cotton you've ever had vitamins in the
top there's a little chunk of free
regular cotton in there and this is
three times softer than vitamin cotton
100% satisfaction guaranteed you're
gonna love these undies and you can
support the podcast and that's what I'm
saying support the podcast so get 15%
off your first pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guaranteed go to me
undies Emme UND IES comm slash weekend
that's me undies dot-com slash weekend
and take care of your great great great
great grandparents DNA with a with a
fresh pair of me undies with that three
times softer than vitamin cotton gang
let's take a comb and the hotline is 95
664 nine five zero three and you can
call if you have anything going on you
want to share a struggle a moment an
experience or chime in as to what
happened in part
show let's hear homeward yo this is Cody
from Newton canvas disappearance list
your podcast and we're talking about
some hardships with being a new parent
and I was just going to say that when me
and my wife found out we were having a
kid I only wanted to have a boy thanks
for calling Cody I appreciate it and you
call you and your wife only wanted to
have or you only wanted to have a boy
you were saying homeward going you know
growing up I always wanted a boy like
coaching sports and stuff and so found
out we're having a girl and kind of
bummed me out and it took like a week or
two after she was born to really feel a
connection with her but now she's almost
three years old and she's totally a
little daddy's girl and uh I spend every
second I can with her and she you know
always wants to be with me and sometimes
my wife gets active she's more of a
daddy's girl than a Mama's girl so uh
and also I was just going to say that I
had a ex problem with being a oxy addict
couple years ago I finally stopped and
got cleaning just wanted to tell you
this podcast helped me out a lot better
so thank you everything you bet man
thank you for the call and thanks for
sharing your story you know you know
when I think about you I don't know you
were when I think about you and I see a
dad you know who's clean and not
struggling with oxycontin's or those
types of pills you know are those types
of [ __ ] spirit week iners a Native
American would never take no oxycontin
OG Native American one of the originals
bruh I'm saying anybody these days hair
body you know if you've the Sioux these
days if you met the Sioux half of them
is probably keyed up on some long
percocets you know I mean I'm not saying
just them anybody [ __ ] half of
[ __ ] half the people with the last
name Walter are probably on [ __ ]
percocets and I mean like a lot of the
nation is setting but it's nice when I
think about you and I think about your
daughter I think about you being clean
man that's a nice it's a nice you know
it's a nice it's amazing what a child
can do it's a nice visual for me to have
a man who got who overcame something
and now gets to spend time with a
daughter that he loves you know that's a
beautiful thought and you know there is
something man look I you know I have
three little nieces in the third one I
don't know that good but man I mother
two nieces man I love him so much you
know in the little ones she used to uh
she was she's like a mimic some kids are
talkative but a lot of is just mimicry
you know they hear something in the and
and then they share it and man she could
do that with them but she would hear
something she would just be shame I mean
it was just she was almost like a little
recorder kind of a little phonograph but
she's still the sweetest and and yeah
there's nothing little girls can be very
sweet you know and there's a man it's
just so it's beautiful it's beautiful to
hear that man and thank you for sharing
that with me you know even just that
fear of like man a girl you know some
little girl gonna be running around the
house you know putting nail polish on
everything you know putting perfume long
you know in my shoes and all of that you
know and you know growing up and you
know turning into maybe a real [ __ ] you
know there's something like that or you
know getting to my little pony you know
maybe a dad is like that it's like tough
to think about that and then you think
about oh I gotta change you know now I'm
have to you know cut her hair short and
you know get her a catcher's mitt you
know and I'm still gonna try to keep her
dating guys but I'm also gonna try to
teach her sports you know it's so I'm
sure there's a lot of that but then you
get the girl you know and then you adapt
and a week later you know those fears or
whatever that was all that slips away in
Love Wins right there at the end man man
that's awesome thank you for sharing
that dude and congratulations
congratulations bruh on being a father
and on being a father over your own
addictions man because dude you're a
daddy to two things bruh you're a daddy
to two things son amigo
homework let's take another call hey
Theo this is Anna calling from just
outside Toronto hey Anna I'll be in
Toronto this week and I'm excited about
it I'm excited about that I'm grateful
to be heading up
Canada dude in Canada that's you know a
lot of people don't think Canada's real
and it is Omer last time I listened to
your podcast you mentioned something
about leaving a message about families
and having children yeah I did on the
last episode was talking about that
because you know have a lot of fear
surrounding it you know I find that I
have some deep deep commitment issues
that I've been dealing with and trying
to you know go to therapy about and I
was trying to think because I've had
trouble in relationships and stuff and
now I'm realizing it's actual commitment
it's a commitment like just it's it's
tough for me but onward I have one child
she's the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me and I just wanted to read
the message about how great it is to be
able to have one child I wanted to have
more than one but I lost many other
children that I tried to have meaning
miscarriages and it was one of the
hardest things that Holloway's ever
happened to me because I always thought
I could have maybe a brother or sister
oh I'm sorry to hear that you have that
you know it's it's a wild it's like you
know there's only so many pathways into
the world you know and and I think some
of us just traffic you know God
sometimes doing that air traffic control
that air traffic crops troll you know
where it's like sometimes you know they
got a detour they gotta bring a kid in
over here because you know the tunnels
or something are they doing construction
or you know and they got to make sure
the kids everybody gets in the world
safely you know two trains coming by and
you know they had a collision over here
and they got twins off the sub you know
this one off the El train and you know
and the you know vagine and all that and
sometimes they you know they it's a lot
of air traffic control but but I'm glad
to hear that you have a beautiful
daughter let's hear more my baby girl
but I was unable to do so and now that
time has passed but I'm so thankful to
have had her she's the greatest greatest
thing I appreciate you calling and
sharing that you know yeah it's like III
you know I me you know women and they
say they don't they don't want to have
children and that's fine you know
children is not for everybody and a lot
of people it's like yeah people like I
don't want to bring children into this
world and no that's fine
you know that's then you're not then you
won't you know and that's fine and I
thought about that you know I've been
blessed with a bunch of nieces and
nephews so I'm like maybe you know
obviously that part of my heart has been
filled up you know temporary these
temporary placeholders in my heart have
been put there to kind of keep you know
are honestly really up dude my family
and I we didn't even really love each
other until my sister had a baby and for
a lot of us in my family it really
brought us together
you know it's so hard to be around a
baby and not uh you know it's crazy the
power of a baby is so powerful
my little niece that she made me love
her mother my sister and I didn't not
love her sister my sister by any choice
of mine it had just been we never really
had any love in our family like that and
and I just Fitz at the end just the the
amazingness the power of that that is
fascinating there's nothing I could do
right now really that would make they
you know that would there's nothing you
can do really there's no magic there's
no David Blaine trick that you could do
that would make somebody feel like that
and would change you know would then
change the feeling you had about another
member of your family but when I when I
spend time with my niece man it made me
love my sister just made me I can't even
tell you it was infectious
was in I mean it was just like she was
like the David Blaine and she [ __ ]
pulled just a love rabbit right out of
my damn hey order cage baby you know and
I've got the ribcage of a [ __ ] large
cat and when I was born the doctor said
that I had the heart of a lesbian and he
vault and he said that for years and he
said that he'd only ever said that to
one other person and that that man
actually ended up dying got hit by a
Amtrak so according to that doctor I'm
that last [ __ ] I'm that last bad boy
with that lesbian ticker in me and so
that's pretty wild I guess there's a lot
of pressure too at times but I'm glad
you had that you know and sometimes in
the world I think you know I have some
friends in there you know there's
superstars and they you know but they
chosen to work so much that they you
know they don't have the motherhood
thing they had they didn't have time for
it or it's not gonna fit into their
lives they built such a busy work lives
and sometimes I feel for them and I
worry something cuz here's my thing is I
think dude a woman making out that magic
you know I'm saying they got that you
know that Siegfried and Roy you know
they got that they got that [ __ ] you
know vulva Copperfield bar they can make
a shot you can make a child coolest
thing I can make dude honestly I make a
pretty badass bread pudding but I can't
make a [ __ ] baby dude and women have
that ability and so sometimes it you
know I'm all for women's empowerment you
know I'm all for women getting a fair
shake in anything you know nothing makes
me mad you know matter I know there's a
man you know I talked about on here
recently that wasn't he you know wasn't
paying my mother fairly and she would he
was making him work hard you know and
she's out there you know toting these
newspapers around and pushing these
magazine bundles I'm pulling him off of
semi trucks and stuff at seventy years
old
that man lied to her whenever he gave
her that you know that uh that thing and
said there'd be somebody to help her in
the just a [ __ ] snake a [ __ ] snake
you know and that [ __ ] makes me mad you
know I'm all about equally equal
everything equally but what I don't like
what I don't like is I don't like what
worries me is is making women feel like
that if they aren't a CEO or they aren't
a bad [ __ ] in a [ __ ] suit then that
they aren't a woman and that's what I
see sometimes there's some young ladies
out there that just you know that I'm
notice and they just uh I don't know I
don't know they almost seemed like they
they don't like being a woman or
something and look I'm you know I'm just
shooting all out of my [ __ ] face hole
but but to me the most in women can do
anything amazing you know I mean in my
imagination Amelia Earhart's still out
there [ __ ] scooting around but but if
you could have the opportunity to be a
mother to do that I don't think what
women should be in the [ __ ] kitchen
but I think dang you get the chance to
be a mother and have something love you
that you created inside of your body and
you want to [ __ ] have you want to
work your way up a corporate ladder and
maybe you can do both and maybe that
maybe I'm just comparing to the wrong
you know but to feel a pressure to do
that I've also just hated if there was I
feel that there's I'm noticing women who
feel like they're missing out on a good
opportunity because they feel like a
pressure to live up to this societal
kind of push that's going on that to me
feels really really manufactured you
know because that's a crazy gift man you
because you got to get here bro you got
to get into the carnival if you want to
get out
Gravitron and do when i was growing up
they had this man everybody Gravitron
and he'd get because we buy us we live
by the fairground so you could go over
so the fair was open Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday you know I'm saying you
can go over there and you know you keep
going to rides and usually you get
[ __ ] electrocuted once a [ __ ] you
know half the people's in recovery and
relapse and not their plug and [ __ ] in
hooking up dangerous rides and [ __ ] was
sharp and you [ __ ] you know when a
couple things that's happy and lose a
thumb and who gave a [ __ ] you know you
need to call that a win but I remember
being sometimes at the I remember some
time being at the oh oh oh so we went
over there on Wednesday we could walk
down from my neighborhood and for $0.25
you you go on the rides and and I've
talked about this before but there was
basically we were experimental animals
they were [ __ ] trying these [ __ ]
out dude
and sometimes I remember getting in one
thing and everybody went to smoke a
blunt or something and we were locked in
the cage for about two hours the dude
[ __ ] forgot idiot and we're in there
just sweating in a [ __ ] cage halfway
upside down on the damn whatever it's
called the appendectomy or whatever the
damn rods were called piece of [ __ ] and
but they had the Gravitron and the
Gravitron you get in there and had this
do they look like slash from Guns and
Roses just long hair and he had just he
had his nose pierced in like 95
different places man I mean he could
just it would take take a do probably in
you know 36 hours to [ __ ] unhinge
himself around a metal detector to so he
could you know pass through a secure
area but he would get the music going
and then and then this dude would
[ __ ] get his damn dick out and I
remembered as clear as day man because
I'm only I only saw probably three adult
dicks as a child and this dude would get
that damn dick out brah and you were
pinned to the wall remember the
Gravitron is a thing that pinned you to
the wall so you can't even move
and you're here welcome and that's when
that do we just play that [ __ ] aired
you know he played that just them that
meet guitar bra that you know that self
dick and this [ __ ] was on I mean just
but that was awesome dude those are the
good times and you'd leave out of there
and nobody wanted to be like because you
were so you know the Gravitron kind of
pinned you back so you couldn't even
move your neck or anything you were just
like damn I'm so dizzy I'm just seeing
you know an extra dick so man that guy
had people caged out and he'd be out
there spraying out and [ __ ] I'm just
glad I didn't catch a little bit of
extra you know that D and now my neck or
something cuz you hit them nuts hard
enough with that wrist wrist and you get
that DNA but thank you for calling let's
take another call in response to last
week about the children hey Co you one
of the moon what it's like to have two
units and I've had my kids turn what the
oldest one is now 11 I got a nine year
old and a baby three year old oh that's
cool man I wish I had like my mom would
have a kid right now because I'd have a
little brother or sister something and
he could be like six or something you
know and dude I would do crazy [ __ ] to
that [ __ ] brah
I make him carry a rabbit everywhere I
make him wearing no shirt either and I
would just write dirty words on his back
bro in lipstick you know what I'm saying
and just let him ride in the UM in the
backseat like I'm an uber driver and
people are like damn that [ __ ] you
see that kid it says [ __ ] on his back
and he's got a damn rabbit eye dude his
badass homework and that little three
year old he's the linebacker of the
family the middle kid he is a little
rambunctious full of emotions but he did
the coolest thing after he started
playing baseball said that he wanted to
go with a mullet so the dude has the
balls to wear the falls
and the oldest one is just the smartest
kid I know
and he is uh he's really stinky right
now but man I love him I love them all
oh well that's beautiful you got that
she got a family they call that a family
and yeah a lot of kid you start getting
that stink come out of you I remember
this one kid you know they called him
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle because his
armpits was like sewers and whenever he
would raise his hand in class people
would be like oh look at the turtles
coming out and he had that [ __ ]
Donatello scent coming out of there you
know that that Raphael
but thanks for calling man a lot of
people loving their families and feeling
uplifted by him and I appreciate that
yeah you know yeah I just think you know
I think about it because that's the
thing I just I think if you're on earth
and you can do that and you feel the
calling now some people don't feel it if
you don't feel it then that's not for
you
you got to trust your instincts but man
to be able to I would just I would hate
to leave the earth and not have had that
experience you know the opportunity you
know to to love something like that you
know buddy mom was telling me the other
day he's like man you know I love I had
lunch with a friend of mine in Atlanta
actually a high school friend from high
school I hadn't seen him a long time was
pretty cool to kind of catch up and and
he was older than me in high school he
was like a year older and it's weird
even now you know 20 years later I still
look up to him as if he's a he's still
like he's a senior and I'm a junior it's
like this weird energy that kind of
never leaves a little bit but he was
telling me you know that he you know how
he loved his you know he loved his wife
and he loved his parents and he never
realized he could love a kid loved
something more that there was another
level of love until he had his children
and that's just fascinating because
that's something that's that's inside of
us that's something that's deep inside
of us man and just
to hit those levels those free [ __ ]
levels of love and all you got to do is
skied up on an egg bruh and let the Lord
just grill that thing up and just that
zygote omelette baby gang gang cam and I
want to tell you right now if you have
friends or loved ones and you don't like
spending time with them well then they
are unruly bastards and what you can do
is is actually play a game with them
called unruly bastards and what you do
is you pick a theme card and and then
you have to everybody in your group has
to present an answer to it and this one
says embarrassing world records to hold
and I would have to say an embarrassing
world record to hold would probably be I
think probably the longest having one of
the longest arms in the world
imagine having is the longest arm
because it's gonna hang off the bed at
night and the cat is gonna [ __ ] it's
gonna hang just far enough down where
it's like almost on the floor and the
cat is gonna just [ __ ] with it all night
and now we just drive me crazy cuz by
day it's awesome you got that thing all
decorated you maybe got you know
ornaments hanging off of it around the
holidays but but man at night when it's
hanging off the edge of the bed and
those [ __ ] cats get a hold of it
that would be the worst so having the
world's longest arm would be the most
embarrassing world record to hold and
that's one of the cards on unruly
bastards unruly bastards is a hilarious
party game for you and your friends it's
super fun it's simple to play if you
come up with the best answers to win and
become the unruly bastard it's live on
Kickstarter right now this is your
chance to get it and be the first to own
it it's only 20 bucks you want to find
out how insane and fun your friends
really are play unruly bastards go to
unruly bastards calm and support their
Kickstarter and you'll get this badass
game that's unruly bastards dot-com
oh man let's keep it cruising man thank
you guys for some of these calls I'm
grateful to have him here
let's get that hit our hey steel this is
a Casper from New Jersey
Casper huh wow man is wild to be named
after a spirit dude you know gin again
[Music]
you know malt liquor
Casper on word but it's a nice name
though that's what I meant to say man
sorry homeward and I'm getting ready to
go to my brother's funeral
he owed heed on the second and the head
phenols in Florida because that's where
he's going oh man I'm sorry to hear that
man I didn't know that this was going to
be one of the calls in here man I'm
sorry to hear that
homeward but he grew up here in New
Jersey and it's hard think about all
those memories that just he and I had
you know cuz this mine
mmm I guess I had the worst month ever
I want anything like a shirt or whatever
but I love your podcast I love you I
love everyone that listens and you know
I felt like I just need to tell someone
man thanks for calling you know I'm
sorry to hear that bro
[Music]
sorry to hear that man I can't imagine
that you know I'm sure that your brother
loved you an addiction is very powerful
and that's one of the scary things about
it is that it's more powerful than love
you know and I think that's one of the
reasons why you know we have to fight it
and
and yet sigh you know I I mean you may
be laughing your thing you know and
you're like you know you're not trying
to enter the best weekend worst weekend
contest you know that you just and I
tried maybe laughs yeah I can't imagine
that you know I can't imagine that and I
can only imagine that your brothers in a
you know a more comfortable place cuz
man when people are attics they just
don't know they don't know they can't
feel it you know the pills and all of
that in that dark magic and that dark
sauce people putting in their body that
[ __ ] kills your feelings first it kills
that receptor you can't feel the love so
you don't know you don't feel it but we
love you too man you know and and I'll
give you a call this week and check in I
want to see what's going on but just
know man that you're not alone you know
and that's the thing like when you know
this is this is your hurricane
Vietnam right now and I'm sure you know
when you lose somebody like man nothing
there's nothing that matter what matters
you know you're you know a hat you have
a shirt you know that stuff none of it
matters
all you are is your feelings at that
point you know all the rest of it it's
all that is nothing you know all you are
is your feelings and man
[Music]
that is very tough but thank you for
sharing with us and don't feel alone you
know right now there's I mean there's
300,000 people that listen to this and
right now there's not one of them that's
not thinking about you and that's cool
man I mean that's power that's powerful
you know and all those people right now
are I
what they're thinking because it's
exactly what I'm thinking
if you bought all eight with all you
know when they're there thinking that
they hope you feel loved
that's it but you feel loved
thank you for calling man um I had I
don't even know what to say after that
and I'm you know I didn't mean to share
that to bring people's spirits into any
special type of place but but this is
life you knowing this is and this is
life and this is not life and this has
been something we've been talking about
on this episode you know it's funny I
was thinking about pro-life and
pro-choice and stuff today I was you
only for a run and I was thinking about
that kind of stuff and and it's just I
mean life is just it is a trip
trip man it is a trip let's take another
call here here we go the hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three homeward mister gone wanted to
call in tell ya hey you got an engineer
down here Oh What did he say
oh my bad an engineer I thought this guy
was using racial slurs homeward and yeah
Sam Weezy Anna I'm working out here a
bad Rouge oh that's beautiful my brother
lives down there in Benton reserve about
a chase bank off Kenmore let's hear more
from Kansas City
what are you doing your spare time
though what I do right now is I'm
putting together a thousands puzzle it's
very curious as to what you do in your
leisure thank you
and may peace be with you well I
appreciate that man I'm gonna pass the
peace you passed on to me on tariffs on
the under the previous caller so that he
can have a little more today what do I
do in my spare time dude I'll tell you
my days are extremely similar you know I
get up I try to keep myself in a good
spirit out of the gate I hit my knees
right when I get out of bed you know uh
and I think I thank a higher power you
know and my mom mmm you know it doesn't
this doesn't have to be any denomination
whatever I think a higher power for
getting me up you know I think a higher
power for the opportunity that's ahead
of me I think I ask I ask the world that
I look at my day as an opportunity like
I don't have to go to work today I get
to go to work you know I don't have to
talk to my brother or mother today but I
get to talk to my brother or mother
today you know I don't have you know I
try to think oh I get to do these things
you know I make a you know I make a
gratitude list and then I check in with
others and that's mild just a morning
routine in my leisure time I might go
see Christopher Robin tonight I might go
see a movie Christopher Robin what else
I've been running Riesling and thinking
about doing the
don't fitness I've been scheduling
people to come into the podcast we got
Brendan Schaub coming in Sebastian
Maniscalco is gonna become an Enron
white is gonna be coming in as guess um
what do I do
I think about stuff a lot you know I
listen to speeches and stuff on tape I
listen to a a speakers what else do I do
like that that's a fun thing I bought
some clay the other day and I'm thinking
about making some little clay figures I
also been thinking about I want to make
a little a show that my nephews can
watch on YouTube because I see them
watching certain types of shows on
YouTube and stuff and I want to try and
make a show and sneak it up and put it
in front of them and see if they like it
or not you know see if I can be
entertaining to them that makes me happy
to make them to make them laugh you know
you know it's so powerful uh you know my
brother has two little boys and one of
them has like the same hair color that I
had as a kid and the other one has the
hair color that my brother had as a kid
and when I see them like spending time
together and laughs and you know my
brother and I didn't have that you're
not talking about this family stuff a
lot it just got me he mowed up my
brother and I didn't have that
experience you know we've we lived in a
nervous environment where we felt a lot
of fear and uh and so we didn't have a
lot of peace of heart that came and left
us in a place where we would laugh and
feel a lot of joy together so it's funny
when I see those kids laugh and feel
good it's almost like I get to live
vicariously through them you know and
it's almost like when I watch them do
that it's like me it's like you know
it's like I'm it's like it's like oh my
brother and I get this now
get this now because there because
they're doing it you know because they
live in a comfortable enough environment
where and I'm not talking like
financially comfortable or anything like
that I'm just talking about comfort of
the heart you know where they feel
comfortable enough to just laugh and
like joke and kick each other and stuff
like that and just you know and uh and
that's funny that's one of the powers I
guess of of having children is to see
them have the joys if there were joys
that you didn't get to have or whatever
to cut off those whatever those troubles
were to cut them off at the pass with
your children and make the world a
better place and that's the thing with
having kids I bet I bet it feels like
you get to make the world a better place
and that's got to be pretty cool
like you get to directly make the world
a better place by trying to to raise a
kid with a good heart so that's got to
be an interesting experience but those
are things that I like to do I would
love to play more video games you know I
want to get into Brazilian jiu-jitsu
I've been doing yoga so that I could get
more flexible to get into Brazilian
jiu-jitsu I'm at like about 40% adult
fitness right now I would like to get to
about maybe 70% by the end of the year I
like thinking about Christmas
you know Christmas is coming up right
around the corner and I love thinking
about Christmas man dude if I could
think about six things all six of them
would be Christmas bro dude you put a
you put a Jingle Bell on a stripper bra
I'll marry that [ __ ] man I love
Christmas dude I love it you know I just
love the joys I love the candles you
know I like you know telling people it's
mistletoe and trying to you know touch
titty and everything and all of that you
know I like all of the fun and
everything you know I like people
wearing sweaters I'm dude I'm coming I'm
thinking about coming up with a line of
[ __ ] savage turtlenecks bro
turtlenecks adjusts a savage on it or
[ __ ] on the back dude they had want to
talk about we're start my racism and
stuff I got earlier they had this day
when I was growing up this I think this
is one of the worst ideas I've ever
heard but you can tell them what you
think
this dude had a hat right he made a hat
and it said the n-word on the back of it
okay the full one set it on the back but
then on the front of the Hat it said
just joking so if people would see the
back and get pissed then he would turn
around and show them the other side it
said just joking
that's [ __ ] ridiculous isn't it
unbelievable let's take a call right
here here we go on word I feel this is
Bianca from San Antonio I'm calling for
a first weekend submission um this past
weekend was the last that I'm going to
see my boyfriend in a while because he's
an army and he's going to beat the plane
for nine months to a year Wow
he deployed for that nine months so he
might be trying to drop that CD seed in
that Vegeta g'd I'm sorry to hear about
that that this is your worst weekend I
mean you're up right now against the guy
who just lost his brother so this better
be good
I'm just joking trying to lighten the
mood a little bit I'll work so I
definitely tough to have to say goodbye
just one love um and he's also your best
friends so it's scary
hmm also the thing you might never see
that person again but overall I do have
faith and in a relationship and I'm
really hoping I could call you honest or
the worse for first weekend submission
to say everything was okay and we made
it through a very you mattered anyways
thanks I love the show and thank you for
always a price on my face to make it up
oh thank you for saying that that I make
you laugh sometimes I mean that me made
me feel good ah well thank you to your
husband or boyfriend sorry and uh and
man that's just you know that says
powerful you know you gotta let him you
know you gotta let him you know you know
what's you know what's coming to my mind
right now honestly is a little bit of
envy because you get to almost have an
experience like I remember I run when I
was young and you know there wasn't a
cellular phones and a cellular
connections so if you [ __ ] saw you
saw a girl you thought you might be in
love with her you don't you might never
see her again or I remember if you were
dating a girl at school and by date and
it just meant just running up to each
other sweaty between class one time and
saying hey once a day and night but that
was dating in sixth grade or seventh
grade or eighth grade but then on Friday
you knew it's gonna be that last moment
and the bus is coming and you're
standing there and years old because you
gotta say bye to your girl and get on
the school bus and you're not gonna see
her until Monday and Monday when you're
a [ __ ] kid is a year away and you
know you're not gonna see on all your
hormones or just running out to the edge
of your body and you got them man tits
and strong B's like your boy had the
other night at the show and you just man
and you just you how you want to kiss
her so bad but you know you're gonna
[ __ ] hug her again just like you've
done the last 30 weeks and 30 Fridays in
a row cuz you're a complete wuss and
that's what you're doing the school bus
comes up and you can hear it and you're
like slow down and it is going slow it's
going slow as [ __ ] cuz it's a school bus
but in your mind it's going fast and
it's all happening so quick and she's
standing there and she's waiting to be
kissed because she loved you but you
just [ __ ] gave her a hard you try to
hug her so hard that you that it feels
like a kiss
because you're just scared you know and
then you go away for the when you get on
the bus and that's it and she has short
hair anyway and all your your brother's
friends are all on the bus anyway so
yelling out the window calling y'all
lesbians because you got kind of a
woman's haircut and she has kind of a
man's haircut and y'all just meet in the
middle and anybody who didn't know you
guys and saw and just would think you
guys were lesbians with good posture you
know a nice skin but y'all are a young
boy a young girl hugging each other on a
Friday and wishing it was a kiss man I
miss those days
because and what I'm saying is I missed
that you you get to miss somebody I know
that's crazy probably to here but man
and then you didn't I didn't get it and
you wouldn't see your girl till Monday
you're like God what could happen maybe
she'll move what if she moves away this
weekend you had no [ __ ] idea but you
get that you get that experience you
know you get to think I mean I I know
I'm sure it's gonna be tough but you get
to miss somebody in these days it's hard
to find it you can't hardly miss anybody
we're so connected but just trying to
make a different perspective but I'm
sure it's tough you know I'm sure it's
tough but y'all got each other you know
and I wish you well with it all right
let's take another call here thank you
for hitting the hotline here we go hey
man uh my name is Dylan all right this
is kind of a weird one but I was out in
LA last week and we went to Comedy Store
last Tuesday and you were there and we
had a little bit of a weird interaction
where I said hi to you and I told you I
was excited to see you meaning your
stand-up and you told me that make one
of us then and I'm curious what about
that interaction seemed to bother you I
just want to know so that like if I ever
encounter you again I can you know make
sure that I
to offend you in any way or bother you I
just want to say hey I love the podcast
and I love your hand up so just curious
what I did wrong there
get back to me deal I hope to hear this
on the podcast man keep keep being cool
brah
thanks for calling Dylan I appreciate it
I don't remember this interaction but I
appreciate you calling 100% so but I'm
playing this out of my head and you said
I'm happy to see you and if I said oh
well that makes one of us
I probably was saying oh well you if
you're happy to see me I'm probably
wasn't feeling happy to see myself you
know it's kind of having some tough
moments last week and especially a
couple of nights when I was at the
Comedy Store you know I had a day or two
last week I didn't really do anything
and and so sometimes the comedy story is
like you know at the end of the day it's
easier sometimes for me to finally get
some motivation and get going and so
yeah sometimes people be like man it's
nice to meet you and I don't be like and
I'll say oh well that makes one of us
and I didn't mean that it's not nice to
meet you
I meant that oh well at least one of us
is excited about me
because I probably wasn't feeling
excited about myself because as I'm
playing that in my head that would be in
my mind that's how it makes sense and my
mind doesn't always make the best sense
but nice to meet you and next time you
see me if we see each other again come
up and let's talk about this
conversation and we'll see if that wing
can go a little bit better let's take
another call thank you for hitting the
hotline what up the oh my name is Mandy
Oh Mandy
I did my first girlfriend was named
Mandy Mandy she was beautiful she was
beautiful
she looked like the kind of Native
American and she was like remember when
you were young and it's like everything
your girlfriend did just everything
about her just made you so damn it rekt
bro you could [ __ ] just hang drywall
with your own dick let's hear more
things for calling uncle back are you
from way back wha huh when I cry more
must be y'all and I'm here in a little
cottage all right with this French boy
and I got your podcast plan and this
[ __ ] is making me dinner and all
you can do is [ __ ] about your haircut
he's calling it a coupe the long gray
which is like a redneck slang term for
somebody with a mullet but yeah I get
grouped in boy I get grouped in you know
I'm that redneck you know I'm that me
you know I'm that that lesbian you know
I'm a duck you know I got up maybe my
parents was ducks you know or somebody
you know a lot of raccoons if I'll be
out in the yard at night I'll turn
around to be [ __ ] six raccoons right
behind me like those dudes trying to
[ __ ] but that's okay the French she's
probably upset I talk about the French a
lot let's hear more like our version and
I keep trying to tell him don't make me
choose between you and him because it's
gonna be here all the way baby
gang gang Oh c'est la guerre my rain set
so is war my queen
that's what that means in French and it
did is so funny that my first girlfriend
so we broke up man and she was learning
French at school was so [ __ ]
immediately I have to win her back right
so I went in bought like nine French
books from Barnes and Nobles and I'm at
the house trying to learn French as [ __ ]
brahh I'm buying French [ __ ] off the
internet I'm buying you know shirts with
like a quail on them and you know um all
kind of [ __ ] you know getting fries and
you know just being French as [ __ ] man
you know buying you know little French
cans a ham and all kinds of [ __ ] and
just talking about French stuff you know
trying to win her back man that's crazy
let's hear more
you know I'll grin so I just want to say
I love the podcast I love everything you
do keep it up and this French
[ __ ] he says one more bad word
about your ass he ain't get no dick suck
you know I'm laying oh come on come on
oh you ain't getting that French Lick
you know and French Lick is actually a
town I think in Alabama well look yeah
the French I give the French a hard time
you know and but look here's the thing
everybody gives somebody a hard time
everybody you know it you start one
plate keep going everybody says ah yeah
it's [ __ ] up here but it's more [ __ ]
up over there you know it's like yeah
you know Tennessee is always like oh
it's [ __ ] up here but it's more [ __ ]
up in Kentucky and Kentucky's like oh
it's [ __ ] up you but it's more [ __ ]
up in Alabama and Alabama was like it's
[ __ ] up here but it's more [ __ ] up
in Louisiana and Louisiana's like it's
[ __ ] up here but it's more [ __ ] up
in Mississippi and Mississippi's like oh
it's [ __ ] up here but it's more [ __ ]
up in France you know in France is like
our swag is is way gear but it's more
whacking zika's our strip you know so
it's you know everybody's got someplace
and I got a dump on the French man
people get French you know he's French
Chris D'Elia Chris D'Elia is French bro
look at him
now think about France tada
dude that dude is the American dude I
doubt it does he believe in America and
freedom doubt it you know that dude has
quails at his house has crazy [ __ ]
pheasants and all kind of stuff bro he
doesn't even eat I've never seen him eat
anything occasionally he'll [ __ ] have
a couple teaspoons of vinegar and then
[ __ ] about it
something's wrong with that guy and what
it is is he's French
cuz here's the thing about French dude
if you
French means French they're unhappy with
stuff but look if you got to blow your
boy down blow him down if he deserves
that hitter then give him that hitter
but thank you for calling bonsoir ma tan
that means good evening my queen
let's hear more all word they see oh
this is evidence from Texas
hey Evan thanks for calling man I
proceed your call I just recently
started doing stand-up time 3 years
clean and sober and but as curious I
used to do a lot of my creative writing
when I was drinking and having a hard
time getting their creative juices
flowing I was just wondering if you have
any techniques on how to channel that
creative side while being sober just
want to know what you think thank you
for calling Evan here's what somebody
told me and it's a crazy thing man I got
a buddy and he's a homosexual
you know he's hundred-percent homosexual
and he's gonna come on a podcast soon
and talk to us about what it's like to
be homosexual and you know and you know
he does the partying and all of that and
chasing that boo-boo hole and all of
that and being a sweet boy and he's
funny guy and he's actually one of the
funniest guys that I know he really
really is and he struggles he struggles
with addiction and I'm not putting him
on blast I'm gonna tell you who he is
but um but he's an open book too and
he's he's really been uh he's really
somebody that I really admire but he was
telling me sometimes he will and I don't
know if you enter this kind of this
things now this sounds French he'll put
a but uh uh a plastic little you know
kind of butt lozenge into his butt and
it makes him think about stuff
open up your mind because some people
they say if you if you you know if you
up if you're a little you know if that
little [ __ ] rats mouth is too tight
that little baby you know that little
rear rats mouth is too tight that you're
gonna your thoughts are gonna be tight
in your next gonna be even be clenched
up you gotta loosen that Bing Bing you
know you got to loosen up that calamari
breath so that's something he said now
I've never done that but I've also I've
considered doing mushrooms but I'm sober
so I think about that a lot you know
would I be willing to sacrifice my
sobriety to do you know psychedelic drug
you know that would maybe that could
have some positive effects I do think
about that a lot I'd be lying if I said
I didn't think about it now then my
consequences would be that I could then
my brain being an addictive brain might
be able to say oh well you did that and
now you you got to get out of jail free
card you can do other drugs you can do
whatever you want so that would be my
concern but that's what my buddy said
put that you know that be pleasee bruh
that butt plug plug you know that plug
and play any of you know and it had
backed a little [ __ ] Brown counselor
and see what happens and see if that
opened your mind get your creative
juices flowing but uh but yeah that's
something you know but otherwise man for
me I think honestly a vacation sometime
or relaxing can help my brain relax
let's take one more call man here we go
hey Theo said man my name is Houston I'm
from Omaha Nebraska Omaha and Wichita is
where Barry Sanders is from I don't know
if people knew that or not that Barry
Sanders is from over there and while I'm
think about football I want to say that
our fantasy team is gonna win
we're playing David this week and we are
gonna be one in one and I also want to
tell people that if you know a single
mom that is in Charlotte or Appleton
Wisconsin hit the hotline and submit
them nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three so we can do something
special for a single
in those cities I would appreciate it if
you didn't say anything to the single
moms yet because I don't want to get
their hopes up you know because we had
to make sure that logistically
everything will work out but hit the
hotline if you know a single mom in one
of those cities who could use a night
out on the town we can treat them to you
know pay for their sitter and and and
we'll go do something nice with them
just so that they feel cared for and and
they can have fun and again the number
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three um okay let's hear more
onward anyways on the phones I got a
question I've been seeing this girl I'm
talking to you like 20 times just a
little bit older okay that fight that
five years older do when I was in high
school and I lived in Arizona
I went stayed at this [ __ ] college
girls place dude and she made me sleep
on her couch bro and I never been more
erect in my entire life and I've never
broken into a girl's place to [ __ ] or
anything like that but I have laid in a
girl's apartment in the in the living
room on the couch and wanted a [ __ ] as
much as possible anyway more anyways we
just kind of hanging out during the
mousies here in their day okay y'all
been doing six more she she told me that
she won't be man and I had kind of
reciprocate those feelings okay she
loves you and you don't feel that way
and I told her like you know she's
phenomenal person and everything and I
don't know man I waited a couple weeks
to see where it went and I don't I don't
feel the same way but she just wants to
keep hanging out and she wants to be
able just keep you know so be think when
I get hey [ __ ] [ __ ] oh that's doing you
know getting [ __ ] French boy you feel
me you get in there but then you back
out that's that French just move ever
[ __ ] it's the most French thing you
can do get in there and show up and then
[ __ ] retreat
get in there or the treat and getting me
nothing to mean um I just I don't feel
comforted in that man little feel right
but I mean if if she's okay with that is
that
helping to do do you think or should I
really just call it quits well it depend
a lot you're not into her for the love
you know he liked spending time with her
she still wants to have sex she knows
how you feel it sounds like everything's
on the up-and-up now if you're starting
to feel bad about it uh I mean I would
trust your instincts but I wouldn't
overthink it Oh word no I could I think
that'd be better I don't know should I
just keep seeing her or just call it
quits just for her own sake
well her own sake you can't determine
that you know her own sake is her own
sake and I'm not saying that to preach
at you or anything and that and you know
what I shouldn't say that I mean here's
what I'll here's what I'll say this is a
better way for me to say this man I
suggest that you know you've been honest
with her if you are being honest with
her and she knows then then then then
you're okay you're not okay in a bad way
were you're like you're not taking
advantage of her as long as you're
respectful to her you know you're
upfront with her about what's going on
and that's what's going on and if she
starts to like you more now if you start
to feel like he gets uncomfortable you
could say hey I'm feeling uncomfortable
I'm feeling like this I'm these are my
worries but but don't but I were I
sometimes I you know I will start
assuming what they're thinking or what
they're feeling or like you know it's
it's an egotistical thing I will do
sometimes where I'll be like oh this
isn't good for her that's up to her you
know people are able to make their own
choices and it sounds like if she knows
and you guys are communicating well then
that's good she sounds like like this is
a healthy scenario I think it's really
sweet of you to call that you care
enough to think about that kind of thing
um but I say trust your instincts man
but I'll say this if you make a mistake
right now with her and in 20 years or 30
years you want to be on the Supreme
Court or you want to do something or
I'm not gonna hold it against you bro
now if it's a real severe crime then
that's different you know if you murder
you blindfold or do something you know
real disaster in naughty naughty naughty
and that's different you know but if you
guys are just being drunk youths from me
and erotic and getting handsy and if you
get too aggressive or you get weird man
I'm I'm gonna understand or I'm gonna
take into consideration that 30 years
later you could be a different person
now if you still doing that [ __ ] outside
at a time saver to 7-elevens brother and
pop pop son you going down you ain't
getting any of that you ain't getting
any of that uh you don't get any
understanding but we all do things we
all make mistakes you're thinking ahead
it sounds like that's not something that
you're gonna do and so I appreciate you
hitting the hotline a share uh just a
reminder for us to think ahead oh man
you know you know what I thought a lot
of this weekend - felt so grateful dude
I got home and I had a warm bed you know
and I had some milk in my frigerator and
my New Orleans Saints was on TV man I
felt grateful you know I felt you know I
just felt grateful that people came out
to the shows this week
you
you know it's crazy
it's crazy man I just never especially
this weekend I mean a lot of weekends
have been great this weekend I just I
never realized there were so many caring
people out there I mean man we had so
much fun we had so much fun dating I had
it was just man it was great it was
great I'll see you guys in Toronto this
week I'm gonna take us out with the same
song that we came in on if I said
something during this podcast you didn't
like or that you disagree with or
whatever that's okay you can hit the
hotline and let me know nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three I've
been wrong about so many things in my
life
today is no different but I appreciate
the people that called in you know I
appreciate the people that you know you
know that left that storm and came and
got that laughter and took it back to
over there from and maybe tomorrow
they're helping somebody you know clean
out their soggy they're soggy life or
helping somebody wring out a family
photo album
you know we try to do things and meet up
and put a little bit of love back out
into the world you know I appreciate the
people that came out this weekend have
fun people that you know sometime I
would think you know I used to look at
certain tight you know sometimes if I'm
around even different ethnicities or you
know Stern women sometimes I feel in
feel like oh these people think because
of how I sound or where I'm from that
they think that I that I'm not gonna
like them and uh and then and then I see
those people and that's not the truth
but I'll act uncomfortable because I'll
think that you know but then I see
people like that come out to my shows
and just say man I love the podcast and
you know I want to be a part of you know
I'm so happy to be a part of what's
going on here and uh a man makes me feel
good so anyway enough enough of this a
penis young man who lost your brother
you know I'll talk to you this week and
I love you bro you know and I'm so sorry
there's a dangerous game addiction you
know it is extremely dangerous I mean
these drug companies this [ __ ] needs to
be we can do better than this we can do
better than this and we will we will as
people man you know I think if we love
each other enough and we found ways to
care about each other enough and we
found ways to you know to prove that
we're not these things we're not the
things we carry we're not our cars and
our and our in our hairstyles and our
skin and our with that we are that at
the base of us
that we just want to feel loved and we
feel that way by loving others
and if we're not afraid to show that the
man we're gonna [ __ ] I do said he
makes puzzles man I swear to god bruh
we're gonna put this whole puzzle
together [ __ ] I feel uplifted now dude I
was feeling keyed out earlier and now I
feel uplifted dude you guys be good out
there man be good to yourselves you
probably deserve it and um [ __ ] I don't
know I'll talk to y'all I'll talk to
y'all next week Gang Gang
hurricane my band of heathens submitted
to us by listener Josh Wilcox onward I
hear the South window the bridges
getting lower
the shrimp boats coming home the old man
down in the corner slowly turned his
head takes a sip from his whiskey pile
and this is what he said I was born in
the rain on the pots of trade
underneath the newsy Hannibal don't mind
the strain of a hurricane they come
around here at you
the high Blackwater a demos daughter
she's hearts it's covered and she's me
but nobody told her it takes a lot of
water to wash away new all
man came down from Chicago he
everybody's got a hurricane man
everybody's got a hurricane you know
we've all got one some people's are
small and some people's are big and some
people don't even know they're standing
in one and sometimes we're standing in
one and we don't even know it
you know but they got some dark fronts
moving in baby
so we got to stay light in this MF for
you feel me gang gang boy you know I'm
Sam bruh I'll [ __ ] a pigeon dude and I
will not I will not
[Music]
[Music]
Danis daughter she's hearts it's colored
she's me but nobody taller it takes a
lot of water to wash away
[Music]
you